open this work made a giant Sidebottom
bubble breaks we need medicine crap dude
a lot of mentoring that's going to work
so I'm going to print the second half
now the second half goes out there is
rail guard I'm just I'm just trying to
make a really cool like tact out like
futuristic aar kind of thing I just
found buried away in the cable box in
the equipment room broken zone it was
not him it was not Peter we got to miss
you to self Peter this was hidden
perfectly clean in the crate full of
offending cable Cameron why was doesn't
occur section there someone broke it and
it was perfectly clean like the
thumbprint or wipe out yeah no there's a
reason that phones that fit in the
middle back grade though it was in the
cables and I was like why is the phone
here and I picked it up like this I was
like blew the phone that we haven't
acknowledged or used ever he broke his
phone when we were shooting anime his
manners I had an uncommon thing prop
that I was using oh it was broke new and
then it got stored in there probably
accidentally ended up in that box
because it was thrown in there while we
were on set mr. Salter yet another salt
it was perfectly clean because I am a
little OCD and I always clean my phone
because I was Jake the whole time I
didn't put it in that box but I was
going broke it and I want to wipe
definitely okay so my first big 3d print
finished I think it's pretty cool weapon
scope basically made for prints here got
two for the front half split down the
middle print them separately glue them
together
got a second happier who the whole thing
together to make a single piece it's
pretty good it's pretty good but you can
see little lines of the print
it's kind of an unavoidable thing when
you're dealing with these types of 3d
prints and it kind of ruins the real
with them especially when you're trying
to pretend that this is some other
material like like steel or aluminum or
whatever there's a lot of ways to deal
with this usually in the past I just use
primer but Nico got some really cool
stuff in called SCC 3d I believe what
this is
a colleague Abbas liquid coating you can
put on your 3d print I think it's kind
of just like a fancier epoxy does it
melt it or what this does is it applies
a very thin fine layer of a hard clear
coat that kind of basically goes in
between these tiny little ridges here
and creates a very smooth outer shape
without sacrificing any detail it
wouldn't look like a 3d printed object
anymore we've tested out really quick
see how it actually functions because
always calling asleep everywhere
this time he was in a really unique
mission is like face down like this I
think isn't cool anymore Nico jazz my
resume we are going up to crest line
California you know two weeks to shoot a
battlegrounds video that's going to be
really awesome
the whole crew everybody get your
sleeping bags get your go packs come on
because we're shooting the video we're
talking about right now is what costumes
we need what people we need and things
we got to build the first thing we have
to do is find the perfect trenchcoat he
goes very very particular about his
trench coats and we have to build a
crate that's six foot tall by six foot
across at the cube that we can somehow
get set we're gonna be up there a day
before I don't know how we're gonna do
it now you guys yes see this graph right
here let's that grab the only way keep
going this way is if you hit the
subscribe button because this is a graph
of our subscribers in the past and about
28 days there's more people that are
watching this video that aren't
subscribed with our people that are
subscribed as what you're telling me to
analytics a just takes that dude I got a
geode I got two Gio's right here oh man
I literally had these yields sitting on
my desk for like three months now I've
got to crack these open I need a hammer
yeah Oh what everywhere in my chill dude
well you got hit in the face that's why
I'm wearing safety glasses glasses
there's literally like I want to put
this in like a corona just like a nice
little summer house sanitary do you
think the inside of a geode is closed
pretty sanitary
very very yeah absolutely like this
hasn't seen the light of day in millions
of years
this is like like a little lime wait
really millions though it takes millions
for this to form and we just probably
good I had a crush and I think sixth
grade instead of like getting her
flowers something I gave her a rock I'm
not even kidding a rose quartz and
fool's gold tiger's eyes hmm great dude
have you never seen tiger's eyes
the eye of the tiger Peter have you ever
lifted two eyes a tiger there like an
old plumber's wait are you are you for
real right now
what is that way from the movies
I don't want to I don't want to breathe
it in you don't want to press it either
or all if you die instantly all right
you put the bat on one part of this stir
it up a little bit so here it is well
goopy bet it smells goopy very simple
sleepy open on flexuz pan we should
sometimes I just put this all over it
looks like ass afterwards I mean just
like whoops there goes 30 hours of
printing oh yeah you can kind of try
this please throwing a punch in a little
by little we'll see little bit with this
get up hey you just got like a speck on
my eye disappearing I just felt like a
small sex hit me
ba-leep on
really well I mean how big are we coming
is it against this but it's really like
six foot better cover bodies from either
side yeah yeah so you know I know what
the toughest class if you're talking
about the waiting plastic they'll
definitely work but what you could do is
doing strips and since it's already kind
of overlaid like that corrugated plan
good you make your taps like that and
then you take a gray PVC pipe like it's
in that old thing holding it together
and put it down the middle to basically
come in tonight either still need a top
there covered with that tarp so
technically you don't need a cop here's
what I think we should do five eight
pieces of that 3x3 to make the five
walls and you have an ultra scope each
with a with the nail gun throw the tarp
on top so when we get to that field it
just direct it lock it in and it's there
to arrangement well get started on this
follow that dab your way right out the
door BAM
yeah we're going to damage is it's only
a day twenty hours Sify muzzle break to
put on the front of the guns couple it
with a scope put a thing on the front
the epoxy coating the X cc3d turned out
pretty well and I've gone as far as also
applying paint over it and so if you
look closely you can see it is looking
very smooth they do not look like a 3d
prints so especially in these areas here
there is no like line texture or
anything along a lot of these sections
up here as well it looks pretty good
it's good it'll be a functional airsoft
weapon to the scope itself isn't
functional yet but I want to carve out
like a little hole here and here and put
actually like a camera in here so
there's just like a tiny little micro
screen okay so the other one was really
hard to crack open it took like six of
ten and then it finally exploded
ah well that one's cool well I think
that the other one wasn't no dude this
108 what a current play cycle sparkly
yes one got those crystal it's almost
like like crystal sugar cut to but I had
a whole pamphlet talking about how they
form and I threw it away a lot of crazy
[ __ ] happened in LA North Hollywood
shootout that's it I just start shooting
at the cops
his actual hits them footage from the
note I would thank you doubt the card
yeah trade me to actual speed man it's
on the news interesting that uh this is
the event that's really cheap based not
just based on just we shot the news
coverage shop shot okay but anybody goes
to this one temperature all the bank you
know it's very way he's always a good
money I didn't hit Sony camera these
guys trained so well like Terrell
attends reload like I can't leave a bag
route would be so get it reloaded now
any actual cops they must have had like
don't worry people but on Thurs is this
is like third yeah them drug there every
day
now you have your absently just to tell
people that nothing's actually happening
film in a movie don't worry because in
order to do those kind of bullet hits on
cars you have to
squit you have just one it's not called
swimming but you have to squib the car
and then you have to put over a layer of
like bondo over it and repaint it so you
can't see it and then you only get one
take like once it goes off the boom like
that's it you have to prep the cars days
or weeks in advance and you get backup
car before yeah yeah and then you need
like everything's multicam what why is
this being heat yeah this is the reenact
your life so it's all we would shoot at
this is the real food right I think is
like actually shooting and anything wise
like nothing that special about the
scene is just like how its portrays a
movie with the characters how they
handle the guns people on the sign
it's really just sounded like more than
anything else the first thing we do that
kind of sound design open its words made
a giant side by muzzle break thing and
it's fitted ideally to just be able to
slide on to the front of the gun that's
going to work so I'm going to print the
second half now the second half goes out
to there yeah you can figure with my
little concept okay
it'll sit at the content area that's
like full outline maybe you find a way
to get this go back of the scope to
illuminate a little like that that we've
sweet so the others I'm not making it
slow so I can actually do the iterations
of the front piece there I started more
like rectangular and then it slowly
evolved into a triangular the final
piece I use whatever glue I can find in
here because every single time we open
up the thing a glue it dries up you know
don't you hate that so every time I work
on a new 3d print grab whatever glue is
nearby
yeah standing it so it helps adhere
industrial-strength I don't know what
this is but it's industrial spring oh no
is this right out okay I was trying to
find pliers I'm just winging this I'm
not an expert so if you don't know what
the word kit bash is tip ash is
basically when you take little bits and
bobs from realize pre-existing things a
really good example of kit Bash is the
designs of spaceships in Star Wars or
even the guns in Star Wars they're
listed and like put together from a
combination of a whole bunch of
different pre-existing items like Han
Solo's gun taking a bunch of little part
collecting and making something new out
of it along here you can see like
there's like little tubes and stuff
there's like little screws and stuff
here and that's actually 3d kit - I've
got my rifle selected here I've got all
my parts printed still have to do the
finishing touches I got to paint
everything and they get all look good
are going to figure out how to get
everything on here nice and secure and
then I'll be done but that's for another
video so subscribe to the same and eco
channel so you get the
whole thing come together
[Music]